parties and girls it's gonna be lit
[Music]
going to colombia looks like i got the
looks and the brains of the family
i'm proud of you okay who are you
governor finn wants all detained
immigrants gone by election day
god i deported
zero tolerance
the d.a is suffering to drop charges if
you volunteers help care for senior
citizens
at alcove we truly appreciate you being
here to help out our seniors
how am i supposed to eat this nasty ass
meatloaf spiker i suggest you say
something you know cause your skin i'm
argentinian
if you stick to the program your time
here should be pretty fast and easy
you wait right here
sorry
you really got away with the ladies
getting out of here what are you talking
about you trying to escape
oh my god
i promise you you stick with the program
you're gonna leave this place more
mature
you may even gain a newfound
appreciation for life
phillips you okay
mr phillips not breathing
am i in here because i'm latino or black
or both
you